[Music]
somewhere near you an animal is
defecating in fact each day the animal
kingdom produces roughly enough dung to
match the volume of water pouring over
the Victoria Falls so why isn't the
planet covered in the stuff you can
thank the humble dung beetle for eating
up the excess capable of burying a 250
times their body weight in a single
night these valiant insects make quick
work of an endless stream of feces over
7,000 known species of dung beetle run
cleanup duty across six continents
everywhere except Antarctica a dung
beetles first task is to locate dung
some live on the anal regions of larger
animals ready to leap off when they
defecate others sniff out feces that
animals leave behind a pile of elephant
dung can attract 4000 beetles in 15
minutes so once a beetle finds dung it
must work quickly to secure some of the
bounty for itself most dung beetle
species fall into one of three main
groups rollers tunnelers and dwellers
dung rollers sculpt a ball of dung and
using their back legs quickly roll it
away from competitors potential partners
jump on the ball and once the ball maker
has selected their mate the pair dig
their dung ball into the soil once it's
been buried the female lays a single egg
within the dung ball tunnelers have a
different approach digging underneath a
path some drag dung down into the soil
and pack it into clumps
known as brood balls dung balls or dung
sausages depending on their shape and
size male tunnellers sport a spectacular
array of horns to fight each other for
control of these tunnels which they then
defend until the females laid her egg
some male tunnellers avoid the fray by
masquerading as hornless females and
sneaking into tunnels to mate while the
guardians heads are turned
the third group of dung beetles dwellers
take the most straightforward approach
laying their eggs directly into a dung
Pat this makes their offspring more
vulnerable to predation than those of
the tunnelers and rollers as the larvae
feed they riddle the dung Pat with
tunnels leaving remains that are quickly
colonized by bacteria and fungi and
weathered away inside a tunnel ball or
pat once the larvae hatch they consume
the dung before metamorphosing into a
pupa and then an adult beetle
besides clearing dung the actions of
these beetles have considerable
ecological importance for one they serve
as secondary seed dispersers young from
monkeys wild pigs and other animals is
riddled with seeds from the fruits they
eat when beetles bury their dung balls
they inadvertently protect these seeds
from predators and increase the
likelihood they'll germinate the
advantage is so great that one South
African plant has evolved to produce
seeds that look and smell like dung to
trick beetles into burying them dung
beetles also play important roles in
agricultural systems livestock like cows
and sheep produce huge amounts of dung
which contains nutrients that can
benefit plants the beetles break up the
dung and tunnel it deep into the soil
bringing the nutrients into close
contact with plant roots their services
to farmers have been valued at 380
million dollars a year in the US and 367
million pounds a year in the UK dung
beetles can even help us battle global
warming by reducing greenhouse gas
emissions associated with farming
microbes living in oxygen-poor livestock
dung produce methane a potent greenhouse
gas but beetles oxygenate paths when
they tunnel into them preventing the
microbes from producing methane the dung
beetles spread seeds helps farmers and
fights climate change and accomplishes
it all simply by doing its business
maybe next time you come across some
dung in the forest or a field you'll be
tempted to take a closer look if you
want to learn more about nature's pooper
scoopers we highly recommend animal
weapons by Douglas J Emlyn this book
includes more wildly fascinating facts
about dung beetles and digs deep into
the survival strategies of animals
around the world read our full
recommendation and snag a copy by
visiting ed ted.com
slash books check out the comments
section to learn more